and a Kendrick is involved in something
and that shaking Blake Lively in their
upcoming thriller a simple favor Brooke
Anderson sat down with the cast for one
lively you notice you in another
conversation one minute started with
Anna's personal rules for success just
take advantage of people yell I try to
throw something in every room I look
does fame does celebrity ever get to you
and how do you reset and get back to
normal okay we know she's joking but
it's that sense of humor that earned
Anna a Teen Choice Award for best tweets
beating out Lakes hubby Ryan Reynolds
and your face Ryan I am soaring with
like yesterday and I did say sorry about
telling you to suck it but I did sort of
admit that there was part of me that was
not just doing a bit and was genuinely
really excited do you have said that
Anna is like the the hotter female her
version of your husband so what kind of
Ryan like quality does she possess
mostly in bed I won't read confessions
no these real-life friends are besties
in their new thriller simple favor
directed by Paul Feig and co-starring
crazy rich Asians Andrey Golding in his
second ever feature film meals I was
coming in as a fanboy were you
intimidated
absolutely well there were times when
like we would be rehearsing a scene and
you would stop and just say sorry I
forgot my line I'm just really nervous
and I was like why is he nervous
like dizzy is he having like a medical
issue boom and Henry maybe they're good
luck charm those other movie crazy rich
Asians topped the box office again and
week bringing its box office total to
over 76 million dollas bankable and a
snackie tree OS Maggie